Ucrania es el elefante en la habitación de
Europa. Pensadlo bien, Europa es el continente
más pacífico del planeta… salvo por Ucrania.
Este país lleva 6 años invadido por Rusia
y la pregunta es ¿Qué está haciendo la
OTAN al respecto?
En anteriores vídeos de VisualPolitik ya
os hemos contado por qué Ucrania es el país
más pobre de Europa. Y sí, es cierto, el
principal factor para explicar toda esta miseria
es la corrupción de las propias élites ucranianas.
Ahora bien, es innegable que la invasión
rusa hace que sea muy difícil que Ucrania
pueda salir de esta pobreza. Fijaos en este
mapa.
Desde el año 2014, la península de Crimea
está controlada directamente por Rusia. Además,
estas dos regiones del este, que se llaman
DONESTK y LUHANSK están controladas por separatistas
que, a su vez, están apoyados por Rusia.
En cualquier momento, Rusia podría intentar
conquistar más regiones. Y la pregunta es
¿Montaríais una fábrica o una oficina en
Ucrania sabiendo que, en cualquier momento,
la ciudad donde estáis puede entrar en guerra?
Y diréis ¡Venga ya, Fonseca! ¿De verdad
crees que Rusia podría invadir más partes
de Ucrania? Y la respuesta es… ¿Y por qué
no? Pensadlo así, la guerra entre Ucrania
y Rusia es totalmente desigual. Ucrania gasta
en ejército unos 5.200 millones de dólares
al año. Rusia gasta 65.000 millones de dólares.
Y eso explica que noticias como esta sean
tan preocupantes.
Ucrania dice que Rusia tiene todavía 100.000
tropas cerca de la frontera
Al Jazeera 11-05-2021
Por el momento, Rusia no ha avanzado sus posiciones.
Al menos no desde 2014. Pero si algún día
lo hicieran… ¿Qué podría hacer Ucrania?
¿Cómo podrían defenderse? Como os podéis
imaginar, la situación de este país es crítica.
Y eso explica que el mayor deseo de los ucranianos
sea este.
Ucrania quiere acelerar la entrada en la OTAN
para enviar una señal real a Rusia
Euronews 06-04-2021
Y diréis ¿Por qué es tan importante que
Ucrania entre en la OTAN? Por si alguno no
lo sabe, la OTAN es una unión de defensa.
Es decir, que si atacas a un país miembro,
el resto está obligado a defenderlo. Dicho
de otra forma, si Ucrania fuera un país miembro
de la OTAN, tanto Estados Unidos como Alemania,
Francia o España tendrían que mandar tropas
para defenderles. Ya no estarían solos frente
al Imperio Ruso.
La pregunta es ¿Es posible que Ucrania entre
en la OTAN? ¿De verdad la OTAN está dispuesta
a aceptarles? Y lo que es más importante…
¿Cómo se está preparando el ejército de
Ucrania para defenderse frente a Rusia? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero antes…
…antes vamos a hablar de defensa… ¡En
Internet! Vuestro móvil o vuestro ordenador
es como Ucrania: está a merced de una invasión
en cualquier momento. Lo que pasa es que,
en este caso, hablamos de invasiones de hackers.
Hackers rusos, norcoreanos y de cualquier
otro lugar. Incluso aunque no seáis conscientes,
es probable que ahora mismo haya un bot que
está leyendo vuestros mensajes y robando
información personal de vuestras tarjetas
de crédito, etc…¿Y cuál es la mejor forma
de protegernos de un ciber ataque? ¡Exacto!
Usando una VPN. Una VPN como SurfShark VPN.
Surfshark es una VPN fantástica. No sólo
nos protege de hackers, bots de propaganda
y virus. Además, permite que podamos entrar
en cualquier sitio de Internet sin encontrarnos
con esos mensajes de “esta página está
bloqueada en tu país”. Vamos, que puedes
visitar cualquier sitio web de forma segura.
Además, Surfshark tiene una herramienta que
se llama CLEANWEB que bloquea todos los popups
de propaganda, por donde se cuelan más bots
y cookies que no queremos tener. Por si todo
esto fuera poco, con una misma cuenta de Surfshark
podrás registrar todos los dispositivos que
quieras ¿Quieres navegar con seguridad desde
tu SmartTV? ¿Desde tu móvil? ¿Desde tu
ordenador? Puedes hacer todo esto con la misma
cuenta de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos un descuento de lujo
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Si usáis el código “POLITIK”, con K
de VisualPolitik, tendréis un 83% por ciento
de descuento más 3 meses extra totalmente
gratuítos. Tenéis el link en la descripción.
No esperéis más y descargaros ya la aplicación.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
VODKA, CHANCHULLOS Y KALASHNIKOV
Dicen que una imagen vale más que mil palabras.
Así que os voy a enseñar una imagen para
que entendáis cómo funcionaba el ejército
de Ucrania hasta la guerra de 2014. Esto que
os voy a enseñar ahora es real. Es un anuncio
oficial para enrrolarse al ejército de Ucrania.
Vamos a verlo porque no tiene desperdicio.
Bien, aquí vemos a lo que sería un palurdo
ucraniano que intenta ligar con unas damiselas
mostrando su flamante BMW… algo muy normal
en Ucrania. Pero de repente, ocurre algo inesperado
¡Aparece un tanque! Algo también muy normal
en Ucrania (por lo visto). Y en ese tanque
hay tres soldados que llevan tanto maquillaje
encima que parecen el novio de la Barbie.
Y aquí se baja el soldado Dimitri y atentos
a este momento.
¡Muy bien Dimitri! ¡Estás conduciendo un
tanque pero te vas a tomar un vodka! Así,
que te de energía. Os recuerdo una vez más
que este vídeo está hecho por el Gobierno
de Ucrania. Osea, esta es la visión que tenía
Ucrania de lo que era su ejército. Pero esperad
que sigue.
Vale, las chicas pasan del palurdo. Ya sabéis,
chicos, si queréis ligar en Ucrania un tanque
es mejor que un BMW.
Y aquí tenéis al soldado Dimitri bebiendo,
no un chupito de vodka sino el botijo entero.
Ahora hablan un ratito… que si trabajo en
el ejército, que si me quiero casar contigo,
que si tienes “insta”… y después los
soldados se van. Ejército de Ucrania ¿Por
qué elegir entre hacer el amor o hacer la
guerra cuando puedes tener los dos?
Bien. Después de ver esta obra de arte, os
voy a dar unos datos que os van a dejar petrificados.
Ucrania es uno de los mayores exportadores
de armas del mundo. Así, tal cual como lo
oís. Durante la Unión Soviética, Ucrania
producía el 30% del armamento de la URSS.
Había más de 1 millón de personas trabajando
en las más de 750 fábricas de armas ucranianas.
Y diréis ¿Qué pasó tras la caída de la
Unión Soviética? Pues… algo que nos os
va a sorprender. Casi todo el arsenal soviético
desapareció. Así, tal cual como lo oís.
Se calcula que entre 1992 y 1998, Ucrania
perdió más de 32.000 millones de dólares
en armamento ¿Y dónde fue a parar todo ese
armamento? Pues a guerras como la de Sierra
Leona, Croacia, etc… Esta fue la época
dorada de los traficantes de armas ilegales.
¡Pero la historia no se queda aquí! Dejando
a un lado a los traficantes de armas, el Estado
Ucraniano también hizo un enorme negocio
con el armamento. Todas esas antiguas fábricas
soviéticas seguían produciendo ¿Y qué
fabricaban? Pues principalmente piezas de
armas rusas. Por ejemplo, la mayor parte de
los motores que usan los helicópteros rusos
tenían la etiqueta “Made in Ucraine”.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2012,
Ucrania fue el 4º mayor exportador de armas
del mundo. Y sus principales clientes eran
Pakistán, China y, por supuesto, Rusia. Todo
esto explica que, hasta el año 2014, la mayoría
de los ucranianos decían NO a entrar en la
OTAN.
Ucrania dice “NO” a la OTAN
No es sorprendente que más de la mitad de
los ucranianos (el 51%) diera una nota negativa
a la OTAN
Pew Research Center 29-03-2010
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando… Entonces…
¡Ucrania es toda una potencia militar! ¿Cómo
es posible entonces que Rusia se atreva a
invadirles? Hay dos cosas muy importantes
que tenemos que entender. La primera es que
Ucrania sólo exportaba piezas para fabricar
armas. Es decir, Ucrania a duras penas era
capaz de producir un arma concreta ¡Pero
no sólo eso! Como os podéis imaginar, la
industria militar ucraniana no era ajena a
la corrupción. Para que os hagáis una idea,
en el año 2010, todas las empresas de armamento
se unificaron bajo un mismo conglomerado:
UKROBOROMPROM. Esta empresa da trabajo a más
de 80.000 personas. Sin embargo, en 10 años
apenas han llegado a fabricar 1 único tanque
entero. Como viendo siendo habitual en este
país, casi todo el dinero destinado a armamento…
terminó en los bolsillos de los oligarcas
y los políticos.
¿Y qué me decís del ejército? Pues viendo
el vídeo que os he puesto al principio, ya
os podéis hacer una idea. En el año 2014,
Ucrania tenía a 168.000 soldados. El ejército
de tierra tenía a 41.000 tropas, por ejemplo.
Pero de esas 41.000 tropas, sólo 6.000 estaban
listas para combatir. Y cuando digo listas
para combatir me refiero a que estaban entrenadas
y equipadas. Osea, sólo 6.000 soldados tenían
cosas tan básicas como botas, traje de camuflaje
y fusil. Con este panorama, entenderéis por
qué la invasión rusa fue un paseo militar.
Y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo ahora
¿Cómo puede defenderse Ucrania? ¿Han cambiado
su ejército? ¿O tarde o temprano se van
a rendir? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UN EJÉRCITO PAGADO POR CROWFUNDING
Por si alguno está un poco perdido en esta
historia, vamos a hacer un resumen: en 2013,
miles de Ucranianos salieron a protestar a
las calles y derrocaron al Gobierno, que era
prorruso. En 2014, Ucrania nombró un nuevo
gobierno que era antirruso. Esto provocó
que las regiones rusoparlantes de Ucrania
se quisieran separar del país. Rusia invadió
la península de Crimea y apoyó a los rebeldes
separatistas del Dombás (lo sé, esto es
un resumen con brocha muy gorda pero, si queréis
más detalles, tenemos varios vídeos donde
lo cubrimos en profundidad).
Como ya hemos dicho, Ucrania apenas tenía
soldados para combatir en el frente ¿Qué
ocurrió entonces? Pues que miles de civiles
se fueron a la guerra por su propia cuenta.
Tal cual como lo oís. Gente como cualquiera
de nosotros, sin entrenamiento, ni armas,
ni ningún tipo de equipamiento que se montó
en su coche y se fue al frente a combatir.
Así es como nacieron los Batallones de Voluntarios.
Dentro de estos batallones había gente de
todo tipo e ideologías. Si seguís canales
de propaganda rusa, ya sabréis que muchos
de ellos eran grupos neonazis. Pero junto
a ellos, también había grupos musulmanes.
Y diréis ¿Musulmanes? ¿En Ucrania? Pues
sí. Por ejemplo, el Batallón SHEIL MANSUR
eran guerreros que venían de Chechenia para
apoyar la causa. Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero
de qué sirve tener muchos guerreros… si
ni siquiera tienen armas? Pensad que esos
voluntarios podrían ser cualquier de vosotros
¿Os imagináis que, de repente, termináis
combatiendo en un frente? ¿Cómo conseguís
un fusil? ¿Quién lo paga? Pues atentos.
The Guardian 24-05-2015
Financiando una Guerra por crowfunding
En una batalla de David contra Goliath, las
fuerzas ucranianas usan empresas privadas
y organizaciones de voluntarios financiadas
por crowfunding para desarollar software y
drones en su Guerra contra Rusia
The Guardian 24-05-2015
¡Habéis oído bien! Ante el vacío dejado
por el ejército oficial, los ucranianos se
organizaron a su manera. Así es como surgieron
ONGs como “Coma Back Alive” que compraba
chalecos antibalas y gafas de visión nocturna
para los soldados. Sólo esta ONG llegó a
recaudar más de 100.000 dólares en sus primeros
45 días de vida.
Y diréis ¿De dónde sacaban tanto dinero
en un país tan pobre como Ucrania? La respuesta
está en la DIÁSPORA ucraniana. Hay más
de 20 millones de ucranianos dispersos por
el mundo. 345.000 viven en Estados Unidos
y tienen dinero suficiente como para hacer
donaciones. Así que, en muy poco tiempo,
los ejércitos de voluntarios recaudaron millones
de dólares para comprar armas, botas y toda
clase de equipamiento militar.
Y diréis ¡Qué historia tan bonita! ¿Verdad?
¡Un ejército creado por el pueblo! En realidad,
hay otro nombre más feo para designar esta
práctica. En realidad estamos hablando de
tráfico ilegal de armas. Y eso explica noticias
como esta.
PayPal no funciona en Ucrania, aunque los
ucranianos encuentran formas de utilizarlo
Kyiv Post 05-10-2018
¡Pero no solo hablamos de PayPal! Una de
las condiciones que puso Estados Unidos para
enviar armas a Ucrania fue que todos esos
grupos de voluntarios se incorporasen al ejército
regular. De hecho, para el año 2019, casi
todos esos voluntarios eran ya soldados regulares.
Y aquí es donde sí vienen las buenas noticias.
Porque estas fuerzas voluntarias están mucho
más motivadas y son más difíciles de corromper
¿Recordáis que, en 2014, Ucrania apenas
tenía soldados listos para el combate? Pues
ahora mismo hablamos de 250.000 tropas. No
tienen un armamento especialmente bueno. Pero,
al menos, todos tienen botas, traje y fusil.
El ejército de Ucrania ha cambiado de arriba
abajo. Pero es mejor que lo veáis vosotros
mismos. Atentos al nuevo anuncio que han sacado
para reclutar soldados.
“This fortress is defended by the army of
Ukraine. Our army”
Creo que sobran las palabras. En cualquier
caso, la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo
es ¿Es esto suficiente para defenderse de
un ataque de Rusia? ¿O sigue siendo necesaria
la ayuda de la OTAN? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
¿PUEDE UCRANIA ENTRAR EN LA OTAN?
Respuesta corta a esta pregunta: no. Quiero
decir, nadie puede predecir el futuro… en
VisualPolitik no tenemos una bola de cristal
pero es muy difícil pensar que Ucrania entre
en la OTAN ¿Por qué? Pues por una razón
muy simple: si Ucrania entra en la OTAN, Rusia
tendría a su enemigo en la frontera. Esto
es razón suficiente para que Rusia pudiera
entrar en guerra abierta para evitarlo. Es
decir, que existe un riesgo muy alto. Y, por
triste que suena para los ucranianos que veáis
este vídeo… la recompensa no compensa el
riesgo. Podríamos decir que esta idea es
la que ha guiado la postura de Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea en los últimos años.
Y diréis… entonces ¿Nadie está dispuesto
a hacer nada por defender Ucrania? No exactamente.
Sólo que lo quieren hacer de otra forma.
Veréis, desde el año 2014, Estados Unidos
ha gastado más de 2500 millones de dólares
en ayuda militar a Ucrania. Puede parecer
mucho dinero pero, en realidad, es una propina
si lo comparamos con los más de 6.4 billones
que se han gastado en guerras en Oriente Medio.
Y sí, digo billones en castellano. En inglés
sería “trillions”. En cualquier caso,
este dinero ha sido suficiente para enviar
un arsenal que ha sido clave para evitar bajas.
Por ejemplo, Ucrania cuenta ahora con más
de 300 humvees, que son esos todoterrenos
blindados que habéis visto en las películas.
También han enviado radares antiartillería.
Se calcula que sólo con esto, Ucrania ha
reducido las bajas en un 60%. La OTAN también
ha enviado a miles de instructores para que
entrenen a los soldados. Y diréis… ¿Eso
es todo? ¿Ni siquiera han enviado cañones
y fusiles? A fin de cuentas, tanto los radares
como los humvees no sirven para atacar. Y
estamos hablando de una guerra ¿Dónde están
las armas letales? Y aquí es donde volvemos
a lo que decíamos al principio de este capítulo:
la OTAN quiere evitar los ataques a toda costa.
El objetivo es evitar que la situación escale.
Y eso se ve muy bien con este ejemplo.
Ucrania obtiene ayuda military de Estados
Unidos, incluyendo misiles antitanques Javelin
Reuters 17-06-2020
¿Habéis jugado al Call of Duty alguna vez?
Si es así, seguro que conoceréis los lanzacohetes
Javelin. Se trata de un sistema lanzacohetes
portátil. Es decir, lo puedes llevar al hombro
y disparar proyectiles que destruyen tanques.
Esto sí es un arma letal ¡Y no creáis que
hablamos de un arma cualquiera! Para que os
hagáis una idea, cada uno de los cañones
cuesta 280.000 dólares ¡Pero eso es sólo
el cañón! Cada cohete vale 174.000 dólares.
Es decir, que un solo disparo de Javelin vale
lo mismo que un piso en casi cualquier ciudad
del mundo. Como os podéis imaginar, estos
cohetes serían cruciales en una batalla contra
tanques rusos. Pero vienen con un pero. Ucrania
no puede tener sus 37 flamantes Javelin en
la línea de combate ¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Están obligados a guardarlos en un depósito
en las regiones del Oeste del país, a cientos
de kilómetros de la zona de guerra. Y diréis
¿Por qué? ¿Qué sentido tiene enviar armas
a un país para no dejarles que la usen? La
respuesta es una palabra: disuasión. Ni Estados
Unidos ni la OTAN quieren que Ucrania ataque
a Rusia. Tampoco quieren despertar la cólera
de Putin. Así que se limitan el armamento
suficiente para disuadir a Rusia de escalar
la guerra.
Dicho de otra forma: es muy difícil pensar
que Ucrania llegue a entrar en la OTAN. Ahora
bien, la OTAN está ayudando a Ucrania para
que modernice su ejército y puede resistir
nuevos ataques.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿Creéis
que esto es suficiente? ¿Volveremos a ver
nuevos ataques de Rusia? ¿Es cuestión de
tiempo que la OTAN tenga que entrar de lleno
en este conflicto? ¿Creéis que Ucrania puede
modernizar su ejército de verdad… o que
va a ser imposible acabar con la corrupción?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Antes de terminar, quiero darle las gracias
a Yago Rodríguez, del canal “Cosas Militares”
por haberme ayudado con la investigación
para este vídeo. Como siempre, no olvidéis
que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.